KARNO TENOVUO: The mission
is to make autonomous
ships a commercial reality.
When we originally
set out to do that,
we thought that it would
happen a bit later, 2025-ish.
Now we see that the market
disruption is actually
happening much faster.
And we need to take into
account many activities.
So we start from the
intelligent awareness,
basically giving the
ice to the vessel.
We are also working on
connectivity solutions,
so transforming the data
from ships to shore.
We're building remote
operations centers.
So basically the
infrastructure that you
need in order to operate
vessels from shoreside
and monitor them.
And then we are developing
autonomous systems
starting from
navigation systems,
but also, then, later on
moving into machinery systems,
so basically covering the
whole vessel that will
be made autonomous one by one.
We're looking to basically
automate the data flow
from censoring to data
warehousing to annotation,
and then to machine learning
models and training the models.
And we're looking to
automate that data flow,
and really, Google is the
best partner for that.
Autonomous ships will affect,
basically, safety, reliability,
and efficiency.
Those are the three main
drivers, safety, reliability,
and efficiency.
That is basically driving
the whole development.
On the safety
side, you will have
a lot of accidents that
are happening today
are happening for the
crew on board the vessels.
And now we can save
a lot of accidents
from happening when we are
actually moving the work
to shoreside, or
then making that work
more automated in the future.
So that is one thing.
And of course, reliability
comes, that there's
a lot of breakdowns today.
The systems onboard the
vessels are not reliable.
So they have to do a lot of
maintenance while in operation
today.
In the future, when the
systems are more autonomous,
they also need to be more
reliable so there isn't
so much need for the
kind of maintenance work
that you have on board
the vessels today.
And then on the efficiency
side, you can, of course,
now have the same team
of experts sitting
in a good office environment
supporting multiple ships
or tens of ships instead of
having technical expertise
in each of the ships.
So the work is the same
but now more efficient.
We can already use a lot
of the solutions that
have been created for other
industries in the machine
learning space, and we can
now apply them to change
the shipping world as well.
There is a lot of things
we haven't done yet.
So we need to, for
example, create now
the machine learning models
and train them for marine use.
We need to basically
gather the data
so that we can train the models,
also, for example in nighttime
and in different
weather conditions
and different viewing angles.
That kind of data set we need to
create so we can have the best
models out there.
In ships you have a
wider area to cover.
We're using LIDAR, we're
using radar, HD cameras.
We have to cover a
wide area because there
can be very unpredicted
movements of a lot of vessels.
That requires a high computing
power on board the vessel.
And the good thing is that
they have a bit more time
to do the analysis, for
example, compared to cars.
Some of the Google Cloud
technologies we're using
include, for example,
TensorFlow processing unit
that we can have on
board the vessels.
You have data jobs.
You have HyperTune,
and then data labs.
Those are the
tools and solutions
that have immediate benefit
for the autonomous ships.
Key takeaway is basically
speed and flexibility
to bring this to
the market fast.
So don't try to do too
many things in house.
Partner, use open
platforms and collaboration
to drive this innovation fast.